it's Canadian a language I dated a girl
from Montreal for a year and a half I
love Canada
all right I've been there twice what is
the capital of Canada
I only know like like 3 cities in Canada
I'm gonna just say them Montreal what's
the other one
Canada's capital Ontario is a whole
place its capital the capital of Canada
let's go with Toronto well my Blue Jays
at it's either Toronto Quebec or there's
something with Victoria in it always a
city who is the president of Canada I
[Music]
don't think I've ever heard of the
president of Canada poutine but I bet
he's bald or like a stern lady they
don't have a president they got Prime
Minister right they got out of that
French influence once you get your up in
your system all you're gonna do is have
prime ministers Stephen Harper Stephen
Harper Harper Harper Stephen Harper
Stephen Harper
[Music]
I was told that there wasn't gonna be
math in this hundred million people
under a million people thirty million
feel like nobody lives there I feel like
I've visited and seen 30 people there a
tenth the size of America Canada that's
pretty big but just because it's pretty
big doesn't mean that it has people
everywhere so it's kind of cold Drake
doesn't even live there so that says a
lot Ryan Gosling Ryan Gosling Ryan
Gosling Ryan Gosling that's the one I
knew that's the one that I should have
remembered because he's like perfect
bear what lives in Canada a whale badger
got to be a be a bear no a moose bear
moose
beaver yeah I'd I knew it was a B and it
was a mammal it's a red maple leaf no
it's a white maple leaf on red red maple
leaf anyway I think I'm thinking of
Japan I do care about Canada I'm from
Wisconsin
although I'm very proud that Wisconsin
doesn't touch Canada people think
Wisconsin does touch Canada but
Minnesota is our little shield and
Michigan they're all half so they don't